Then nav modifiers, we've already touched on this a little bit,
but just to actually show you them being implemented very simply.
The easiest way to introduce nav modifiers is if we were to,
they can have an independent volume,
so nav modifier volume here,
and you can see just by putting it here,
this is blocking off the geometry.
When you create a nav modifier volume,
you get to choose an area class.
You can create your own here if you need to do something slightly different.
But by default, we have a null,
which is this, I'm blocking off this space as non-navigable.
But we can also do obstacle,
which is essentially an area of high cost.
What you'll see is if I were to put this nav modifier volume here,
when I tried to get my agent to navigate from here to this point,
it's actually going to navigate around that space.
If I were to put this like this,
you see it goes really far out of the way to navigate around that space,
because we've marked this as high cost.
Nav modifier volumes just give you
a very easy way to introduce the idea of high cost areas,
where the AI will choose it if there's no other path.
It lets you define spaces that are completely non-navigable,
even though there is no other collision geometry that would block that.
It gives us the capacity to change our nav mesh.
The other thing to mention here,
we already talked about the idea of having possibly dynamic nav mesh.
If I were to go to runtime,
if I just move our nav modifier out here,
and I were to just play,
and then I eject and I find my nav modifier volume,
you'll just have to trust me that it's there.
Unfortunately, we don't get
the editor handles when we're in play and editor mode.
If I were to snap that down to zero,
you can see that that's actually carving out this space at runtime.
The reason that's working is because our nav mesh modifier
is set to dynamic modifiers only.
If I change this to static and then I go to play again,
same thing, go to nav modifier volume,
and I were to snap that to zero,
you'd see our nav mesh doesn't change,
and that's because it's now in static mode,
so it's ignoring any dynamic changes.
That is a unique power given to nav modifiers,
is the fact that we have this second or third state
for our nav mesh where we can be fully dynamic
and then obviously would pay attention to modifiers,
or we can ignore other kinds of actors,
only pay attention to nav modifiers,
so we're gaining some of the performance benefits.
We're not trying to consider every kind of actor,
but uniquely allow modifiers to change our mesh at runtime,
and then that's another area where nav modifiers and
nav modifier volumes can give us extra functionality.
Onto the environmental query system,
we've talked a lot about how we're able to navigate space,
but one of the important things when we're talking about
querying things about the environment,
is the ability to ascertain where we even might want to go.
A typical thing that you might see in
maybe a third person shooter,
is you have an enemy who seeks out cover.
So we've got the navigation which can get us to that cover,
but how do we choose which cover to go to?
That's somewhere where our EQS,
the environmental query system, can come in.
So the environmental query system allows AI to gather,
well, not just AI really, anything in the game,
and it is powerfully used by AI, but it isn't unique to AI.
It can actually be used in gameplay as well.
It's basically a way to query things about the environment,
to construct, to ask questions about our environment,
construct a bunch of tests that say,
you know, I want to seek out the nearest suitable cover
for this kind of enemy,
and then choose the location based off that query.
It's worth mentioning that whenever we're talking about EQS,
it is blocked behind a plugin,
so the environment query editor plugin.
I think when you start a new project,
usually this is enabled by default,
but just to kind of highlight that,
if we go to our plugins window and we do environment query editor,
again, I think it's typically on by default,
but just know that if some of this EQS functionality
doesn't seem to be available to you,
just make sure you've got this plugin enabled.
And then yeah, essentially, kind of fundamentally,
it lets us make these queries,
and we use a combination of generating points,
querying that, filtering and scoring
to give either the best result
or a couple of different options for either, you know,
randomly choosing from the best 25%
or the best 5%, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Yeah, environmental queries can be called from Behavior Tree,
can also be called from C++ and can be run in Blueprint,
so it's not purely for AI,
it can also be used for gameplay.
I've used it previously, for example,
when generating points to spawn enemies at,
or points where you might want to spawn drops,
maybe you don't want to spawn your drops
on top of any pre-existing enemies,
you could use an EQS to kind of evaluate that.
So the three key components that go into making up
the EQS system are generators, contexts, and tests.
Generators are essentially the thing, the first step,
they're the thing that we say,
the kind of fundamental makeup of an EQS query
is a carpet of points.
We essentially generate a carpet of points
around our world.
It's the generator that's actually used to define
where should this carpet of points be,
how should they be laid out?
So we have a couple of different classes available to us
by default, we can generate those points in a circle,
which is just, we define like a radius
and then a, you know, degrees around
or a kind of radians around, not even radians,
centimeters around the circumference of that circle.
We can do a grid where we specify essentially
a kind of 2D cube, a 2D square,
and we say every 50 centimeters wide
and every 10 centimeters in depth generate a new point.
And then we have a donut,
which is a little bit similar to our circle,
but it's the idea that we might have multiple rings.
So we kind of generate in rows.
Yeah, we can talk about, we can look at each of these
kind of actually in the editor,
but we have a couple of different ways
of generating these points.
And they are essentially, again,
used to produce these locations
and it's this kind of carpet of points.
And it's then that carpet of points
that we perform the tests on
to actually give us our final result from the query.
And also, yeah, custom generators can be created
in Blueprint and C++ if, you know,
circle, grid, donut aren't unsuitable to what we need.
Contexts are an important element.
They're neither, the kind of,
the generators are what generate the points
and the tests are what test those points.
But the contexts are things that are used
at various points,
either within the generators or the tests.
They're a kind of frame of reference.
So you'll see as we kind of quickly diagnose
some preexisting EQSs that I've made,
the kind of various points at which we can use
the various contexts,
but they kind of give us a, yeah, a frame of reference.
A context can return either a single entity or an array,
but it's just important to mention
that not all things that might be used in that context
are set up to handle a context that can return an array.
Some of them are only set up to handle a context
that returns a single item.
So a context might be the actor
actually creating the EQS query.
That would be the kind of one of the standard
query context is querier,
the person who is actually making this query.
Another example of a context might be
all the rooms in your dungeon.
You might create a custom context that says,
oh, use my room logic to return an array
of all the rooms in my dungeon.
And then I can use all the rooms in my dungeon
around the generator or the tests for various reasons.
So again, these contexts are kind of
between the lines here,
the generators and the tests are the key points
and the context can be used in each of these situations.
And finally, we have the tests themselves,
which are actually used to determine
which these tests are gonna basically run
filters and scoring on each of these points
that the generator has generated
to establish whether or not this particular
and individual point should pass the test.
And if it does pass, if it does not get filtered out,
how should it be scored?
So if we were to, the easiest thing to do now
is actually just quickly jump into an example.
So if we go, this should be in your project
if you've downloaded that.
So in the EQS folder,
we've got two different EQSs that I've kind of made here.
So as we can see, I've made a doughnut
and this is just gonna kind of generate
several rings of points around our context.
And as I mentioned, our center is defined as an actual,
this is where we would use our context.
So we have, our doughnut is using
a custom context that I've made,
which is based off a target actor key,
so a blackboard key,
rather than the person who's asking the query,
this is intended to generate points around the person
who we want to attack, essentially.
So that's coming from a blackboard key
and that's what I've made a custom context for that.
And then we've got our two, these are our tests.
So our doughnut is gonna generate
around this particular context.
And then that's gonna generate
based on what our doughnut says.
So we've got an inner radius and outer radius
and how many rings we need to generate.
So we're gonna start at a radius of 100
and we're gonna generate three rings between 100 and 200.
And every ring is gonna have eight points.
And this is, that's just our initial generation.
And then we're gonna run these tests
on each of those points that we've generated.
So, you know, three lots of eights,
we're gonna have 24 points.
First thing we're gonna do is this path exists a test.
This is a pre-existing test that exists in the engine.
This is essentially say, can we nav to this point?
And then secondly, what is our distance from the point?
So as I said, tests can be either
a test that filters points out,
or it can be a test that scores them, or it can do both.
So in this situation, our path exists,
purely filters them out.
It just says, if we can nav to this point,
if this point is on navigable space,
then it would pass the filter.
If not, then it fails the filter.
And then this next test that we do is based off distance.
This hypothetically could filter points
if it's too far or not far enough, and it could score them.
But in the context of this distance 2D,
which is again another pre-existing filter,
I've chosen to score it only.
So I'm not gonna filter any points using this test,
I'm only gonna score them.
And I've said it should score based off 2D distance,
not 3D distance,
so I don't want to care about verticality here.
And then I've just set some things
about our scoring equations,
so that this is essentially saying that
if we think that distance from the querier
is gonna go up, that number is gonna get bigger,
so the default scoring is gonna be further away is better.
So by inversing that scoring,
I'm essentially saying closer is better.
So I want a point that is closer to our querier.
So a point, the querier being the person asking the EQS,
so in this context, it's the AI asking the question,
I want a point that is closer
to the person actually making the query.
So we can see here how we've used generators,
that generator has used a context.
Our path exists, test has also used a context here.
So the context here being that standard default context
of the person who is actually making the query,
so that's our AI.
And this is asking whether a path exists
to the point from this thing.
And similarly, our distance, we've used a context again
to say, I want the distance
from the person asking the question.
I could alternatively change the context
to be our target actor,
and then that changes the meaning of this distance.
Then I'm asking, what is the distance from the,
I want the point that is closest to the actual target.
Whereas this is saying, I want to choose the point
that is closest to the person asking the question
to myself, the AI.
So a kind of important thing to,
it's all good to talk about all of this in context,
in kind of like broad concepts,
but when we're working with this,
the environmental query system,
obviously at some point,
it's helpful to actually see some of this stuff, right?
Because it all seems so abstract.
So one of the important things to remember
is that there is a very, very powerful Pawn
that we can utilize to kind of visualize
some of this stuff, and that's the EQS testing Pawn.
The way to put one of these in your level
is similar to our NavLink proxy.
I don't think you can just find it unfortunately
through the normal place actors.
So there is probably some other way to navigate to it,
but the way I typically do that is just I go to all,
and then just search for EQS Pawn,
and EQS testing Pawn comes up.
You can just drag this into your level.
And then this is just a Pawn.
You'll notice whenever you do that,
you'll get a, it will bring in its own AI controller.
So if you need to delete this,
when you go to delete your EQS testing Pawn,
you'll get a complaint from your level,
because this EQS testing Pawn
is being possessed by this controller.
So if and when you do go to delete your EQS testing Pawn,
just be aware it brings in its own controller
and you need to delete both.
But what you do with this Pawn
is you essentially just say,
you give it an EQS to visualize, to test.
So you can choose from any of the EQS's
you've already made.
And you can see that this would essentially
just generate this carpet of points.
Now, this isn't gonna be perfectly set up
because this is relying on,
if we actually, again, go and look at this,
go and look at this thing.
It's actually, this context here
is relying on this EQC target actor key.
So that this context is reading from a key
from our blackboard,
which is relevant at runtime for this particular AI.
But in the context of in editor time,
this might not always be suitable.
So it's worth kind of bearing that kind of stuff in mind
that when you're doing custom contexts,
you need to be aware that if you want
to be able to debug this properly at editor time,
it might be worth kind of accounting for that
and adding in some kind of default behavior.
So if I were, the way I can kind of like,
actually do that,
I can just quickly demonstrate how we might do that
is I will just quickly do query a blackboard.
But what I'll also do is if that value is,
for whatever reason, null,
if I'll check if that is null,
you can see it defaulting to just say
around the actor itself.
What I'll change this to is instead,
I'll do get all actors of class.
So this is the custom,
this is the actual in custom context that I've made.
This is the actor that represents that.
And you can see, not actor, sorry,
the class that represents that.
And you can see it's got these two functions
for provide single actor and provide single location,
and similarly provide actors set
and provide location set if you want to return an array.
So I'm just going to get all actors of class,
and I'm just going to look for character,
and I'm just going to return the first character
that we can find.
Better yet, actually, my player here
is represented by the BPAI player char.
So I'll just quickly hook that up
and then get actor location.
Obviously this particular setup wouldn't work
if there isn't one of those in your level,
but this is just to demonstrate
how you might handle this in a way
that kind of appropriately visualizes in editor.
One second, why is that not,
is that actually finding the key?
Maybe I just need to reassign that.
Yeah, there we go.
So obviously we don't know that this would be the target,
but just to kind of give us
a slightly better demonstration
of how this would actually visualize
if we don't seem to be finding this blackboard key
on our blackboard, which we won't
because we're not on runtime,
so that blackboard key hasn't been assigned.
We're just going to fall back to finding,
trying to find a player in the level
and getting the first one
and pretending that that acts location is our target.
So then that gives us a kind of
slightly better visualization
of what this EQS is actually going to do.
It's going to generate points around our target,
but then it's going to score our points
based off whether or not we can,
based on what is closest to the person making the query,
which in this case is the EQS testing porn.
And then we can also see what happens
if we move our actor here.
We can see it's going to, maybe I need to refresh that.
You can see that filtering taking place.
So this is kind of important thing to bear in mind
with the EQS testing porn,
is that these red nodes with zero
don't necessarily mean they're never going to be considered.
If you're doing an EQS query where every point is valid,
then this is still a valid point.
It's just getting a score of zero.
The only points that are actually getting filtered out
are these hard dark blue ones.
So the scoring mechanism goes from red to green
based off how high the score is.
The points that are hard getting filtered out
by one of the filters are this dark blue.
And they, rather than showing the score
that they're receiving, they'll show a,
they'll print out a bit of text to say
which of these tests was actually filtering this point out.
And that brings us back to kind of one last thing
to bear in mind when you're kind of structuring
these EQS queries is that it's good
to be doing your filters first, essentially.
If you can, going from like a top to bottom,
if you're kind of putting your filters first,
that means that your scoring queries
won't be trying to score items
that are never going to be considered
because a filter later is going to filter them out anyway.
So that's just kind of like a little thing
to bear in mind when you're making these.
But either way, you can see kind of by
what's been demonstrated there that that's just a way
to make an kind of intelligent decisions.
You can imagine the same thing.
As I said, I've done this for games in the past
where I've used this to query all enemies
in your current room and find a point that is,
and then score them based off their distance
from all of those enemies.
So you can find a point that is most likely
to not have an enemy currently overlapping it.
And that's where we should spawn our item chest,
for example.
So you can use that in kind of gameplay context.
You can use it in AI contexts.
Yeah, we'll actually come to another example
from one of the Unreal templates in a little bit
where we're going to kind of stitch all this stuff together.